stone dans le tableau est juste après 40
ans c'était rafa est ce que tu t'es dit
non mais quel tableau enfin c'est
catastrophique le tableau avoue deuxième
tour c'est rafael nadal non bien sûr
c'est catastrophique de avoir l'option
de jouer nadal au 2e tour mais au point
où j'en suis au sur un retour je me pose
pas ce genre de questions puisque j'ai
perdu au premier tour je savais que le
premier tour a été elle est très
compliqué et vraiment je suis vraiment
en train de me reconstruire physiquement
et tennistiquement donc je regarde pas
trop loin les tableaux c'est comme un
chroniqueur fait 6 à 7 ils regardent pas
tpp
[Rires]
posez-moi les bonnes questions mais pas
savoir quand est ce qu'on prend
conscience qu'on peut devenir un grand
joueur parce qu'il ya des gens qui
jouent très bien au tennis mais la
bascule quand on est à 0 - cana quand
ceux qui passent de moins 30 à au dessus
dans les dents les meilleurs comme est
ce qu'on comprend qu'on est dans un
chose ainsi que deux champions ça dépend
beaucoup de la mentalité et de ré de ce
qu'on se voit comme on se voit de la
confiance en soi moi ç'a toujours été
par étapes moi la première étape ça a
été d'être un joueur professionnel
c'est-à-dire dont vivre c'est-à-dire
d'arriver dans le top 100 une fois que
j'arrivais dans le top 100 c'était ok
j'ai envie de rentrer dans le top 50 et
ainsi de suite c'était toute ma carrière
a été par étapes et jusqu'en finale de
grand chelem et contribue au final je me
suis dit ah bah tiens je peux peut-être
en gagnant
ses bons mots qui me suit exactement
même chose ce
match s'annonce ya dans mon sport aussi
sur paris après les autres mais c'est
vrai que vu que la banque s'était auto
dans le top 100 bien sûr mais c'est
comme ça qu'on 100 millions top 50 a que
50 cent cinquante
[Rires]
région il a dit c'est déjà passé on a
une info allez
vous poser une question concernant cyril
il le dit lui même en ce moment je suis
un monstre au niveau du sport à 2
musculation tennis est ce que c'est vrai
ou est ce que c'est une banane je pense
que musculation il ne connaît pas ce mot
oui
[Rires]
à
[Applaudissements]
de plus tôt je suis et les bus qui
n'avait jamais vu la salle alors on se
croise
on a une salle
[Musique]
alors parlons alors oui c'est un monstre
mentale s'allient pour moi c'est une
bête mental et c'est pour ça qu'au
paddle il progresse aussi rapidement
c'est qui c'est rentrer dans la tête des
autres il sait se battre ça oui
d'ailleurs je les regardais ce week-end
son tournoi de padel on à milan dans les
écrans partout un monstre un gros
embrouilleur un montant non si vous êtes
un brouilleur ma tête tellement la
veille avant il m'a dit tu as gagné au
mental mais cette année me connais bien
mais vous avez un gros mental ouais
ouais oui daniel vous aviez dit tout à
l'heure que vous redis autour de la
chambre de cyril est ce que vous auriez
le plan de sa maison parce que moi j'ai
été une fois j'ai toujours pas trouvé sa
chambre
enfin petits croquis j'ai le temps de
regarder
connais toi toi il faut bien une semaine
pour bien
je vous dise la vérité hier et hier soir
il m'a fait une petite note il m'a dit
alors je t'explique ce qui va pas dans
la maison loria sayah sayan
joueurs c'est vrai
ça ne va pas d'orangina l'acte ah je me
suis réveillé à 6 ans le matin j'étais
en chercher à des rumeurs disent que
vous craignez cyril sur un terrain de
tennis et gants m son charisme vous fait
perdre vos moyens
je travaille toujours à susurre magazine
une petite question qui n'est pas
sportif parce qu'on l'a vu au cinéma
récemment je sais que ça impliqués dans
la production cinématographique bien
marché d'ailleurs le fil très bien
marché justement est ce que tu as envie
de jouer deux fondateurs moi je suis sûr
que oui non non non
j'ai monté ma boîte de production et on
a fait on a fait ce premier film on a
lancé d'autres films d'autres projets en
cours génial d'instruction je serais
content de rentrer dans ce domaine
maison de retraite il a plein de projets
un stade et pour l'instant il valait il
va aller chercher un autre enjeu les
méchants avant de finir chercher un de
grand chelem je le sens dole sens c'est
un coach mental ce que je dis je le sens
ahmed mohamed l'émoi des petits copains
laly nadal
moi je leur dis moi dirige il laisse
deux jours moi tu vois à l'esl et moi 2
jours motors oui lui apprécié cette
question quel est le grand chelem que
vous rêvez vraiment quel est le plus
prestigieux pour vous et deuxième
question à votre niveau combien leur par
jour vous entraînez quelle est la
cadence c'est plus tennis mais pour moi
c'est toujours été roland garros je
viens de suisse côté francophone j'ai
énormément d'amis sur paris et je l' ai
gagnée en tant que j'ignore si c'est le
tournoi qu'on regarde et on gêne donc
ç'a toujours été sur lui a donc ça a été
un rêve achevée quand quand je l' ai
gagnée est actuellement non actuellement
c'est beaucoup on peut passer entre deux
et quatre heures de tennis par jour plus
une à deux heures de fitness par jour
mais pas dans la maison tirée
[Rires]
c'est un régime particulier à la bombe
ont secoué hier soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces combats lancés et balancé genre à la
[ __ ] du purin à perm en moi je vais
pas ma carrière tennistique est derrière
moi mais je laisse derrière moi aller
derrière moi tiens on va regarder je
veux revoir ta victoire à roland garros
en 2015 et je me rappelle que j'avais
parié sur toi tu à venir j'avais dit
wawrinka en quatre sets contre djoko
j'avais gagné c'était wawrinka en quatre
sets grâce à toi je peux monter ce
plateau
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
6/3 6/4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et détaché un
installeur
papapapa temps ma pomme
[Applaudissements]
amen les mois relaté copains
les nadal allait fermer ni moi pas je
parle de deux heures tu vas dire
t'inquiète pas je leur parle et là les
briser c'est ça aussi les superstitieux
parce que beaucoup bien sûr des hauts
niveaux sont superstitieux à l'époque on
avait beaucoup parlé du short du fameux
short magique mais est ce qu'il ya des
rituels des trucs comme ça d'un outil
nomade et superstitions non j'ai
toujours été anti superstition justement
pour pas rentrer dans la dent dans ce
problème de devoir toujours avoir les
mêmes habitudes les mêmes choses jour où
tu les as pas ben dans la set sera pas
manager côté anti si son travail la
plage est petit il veut pas marcher sur
les lignes ça mais pour lui ça marche et
la majorité se pressent des toc toc mais
aussi
comme et oui tu annules choisi des
balles à mon partenaire je n'en prends
pas cette balle j'ai mis la balle bien
un endroit sûr le filet ouais et quand
je m'assois chez c'est vraiment que mes
coups ils soient bien parlé
[Applaudissements]
tuez-moi
surprise
on met la clé sous la porte
c'est impressionnant
mais c'est des rails mirail non
franchement oui
oui vous à une question c'est une
question oui de roland garros vous avez
dit c'est le tournoi que vous avez
préféré celui que vous voulez aller
chercher maintenant c'est lequel qui
vous fait vraiment qu'il vous fait
kiffer les swing deuxième fois vrai et
je le veux mais sur pellicule
c'est actuellement c'est c'est
impossible pour moi de penser comme ça
je suis je suis pas en forme je suis pas
au niveau pourquoi on me dira ok
maintenant j'ai envie de gagner tel et
tel tournoi mon but c'est vraiment de me
remettre en forme pour avoir la
possibilité le niveau de me battre avec
les meilleurs et ensuite de gagner
n'importe quel titre j'ai plus gagné de
titre depuis depuis 2007 j'ai été blessé
plusieurs fois plusieurs opérations
depuis est vraiment mon mon but et mon
kiff c'est d'essayer de revenir à un
niveau vraiment je peux vide de gros
matchs de belles émotions de jouer sur
comme hier malgré la défaite ça a été
essayé de c'est difficile mentalement de
perdre et de l'accepter mais c'est des
moments incroyables de vivre des sur des
tournois c'est l'anglais n'a culture
comme ça toi même nous pas en forme on
s'en fout on dit même si on n'est pas en
forme novice quand même des trucs
impossibles là il faut les surmonter la
crise
on n'est pas en forme lula temps de se
remettre en forme
a compris ce que tu dis ne pense pas
elle note en font ce pas bah oui vous
connaissez très bien la france et les
joueurs de tennis français pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils aient un creux en ce
moment pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'y arrive
plus du tout en tennis il peut pas dire
ça non il ya un changement de génération
simplement il ya un changement de
génération il ya eu quatre cinq joueurs
exceptionnels
à 31 ans malheureusement avec les trois
phénomènes djokovic nadal federer
manille - ils ont raison ils ont pas
réussi à prendre de grand chelem mais
ils ont des carrés incroyable
exceptionnel et ga quel français sentent
pas encore
ce que vous pensez que titi passer
encore des chances dehors de rares mais
quelques jours des chauvins grecque
pour cette année les pronostics jeumont
pronovost ça y est la jeune espagnole
canal même nom on a su en elle même on a
dit c'est toujours coaché type à son
final oui ces petits badges aux contres
gagnants
n'oubliez dans
l'espace comme moi tu es mon fils parce
que titi pas s'il a un tableau j'adore
tes type atmea un tableau il ya personne
tout le monde est dans le haut du
tableau tadjau coûte 1 nadal tu as
alcaraz donc forcément et puis veux pas
je pense quand miley plutôt tranquille
et en os ça va il ya un quart de finale
djoko nadal mais je pense que djoko il a
faim en plus il énervé de ces masses en
australie donc à mon ami mais j'ai bien
dû au coût moyen ça joue bien eu la
dorsale alors humainement voilà les deux
joueurs préférés mais c'est qui ça
change mais au cours de ma mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
genre préféré c'est stan à laurière mois
suivant le match en plus j'étais dans la
merde parce que comme c'est un français
qui jouait contre olten et moi j'étais
avec la casquette stan de man est tous
au cas où les mecs m'ont regardé match
j'ai pris j'ai caché tu vois
les stades à l'étude
je suis français
non mais c'est vrai les gars de garenne
à toi tais toi testan tt marie nagy oui
voilà mais bon je suis quand même
content qu'un français gagne et
qu'aujourd'hui en quoi la wii qu'est-ce
que vous avez une question ouais moi je
veux juste savoir combien de l'andi
parlait alors de longues robes aux
épaules voire déjà bien le français
c'est déjà beaucoup giguère quand tu pas
bien non que tu adores ciel on a produit
autant
ce que je disais toujours en avait pas
voulu me faire je parle d'aider chaque
travailleur français je parlais de mon
anglais n'ont pas des toiles en anglais
anglais un peu espagnol on peut soit
comme moi
l'espagnol ne vous je parle espagnol
et un petit échange avec stone espagnol
[Rires]
j'ai dit ma conversation
une bonne saison là et passe à quai par
fax
l accent mexicain ça ouais c'est tout
moi je vois pas la gauche
est au lit elle arrête les commentaires
yeux
assez bon